[Musik]
hallo
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
es geht schon wieder gut los meine Damen
und Herren allerdings darf ich euch
recht herzlich willkommen heißen zu
einer neuen Episode Skyblock mit Luca
der Typ hat sich glaube ich irgendwie
unsichtbar verwandelt dieser komische
Händler es ist aktuell noch nachts und
die Monster fahren
moin es läuft doch nicht so gut
tatsächlich wir müssen ja auch noch ein
bisschen höher bauen damit die dann alle
runterfallen und dann irgendwie dann
sterben oder so keine Ahnung wir haben
für heute allerdings ganz ganz viele
andere to-do-sachen auf unserer
To-Do-Liste denn ich möchte heute
zunächst einmal zu dieser Insel da
hinten hin denn wir brauchen den Sand um
endlich mal wieder eine neue Challenge
zu machen und zwar 16 Glasscheiben und
diese Glasscheiben benötigen wir auch
denn ich möchte heute auch die Challenge
schaffen dass ich mir ein neues Haus
baue bzw überhaupt endlich mal generell
ein Haus baue das ist auch ein Teil
einer Challenge und das werden wir heute
auch hoffentlich schaffen
von der euch direkt eine stabile lange
time Labs wie ich koppelt sondern abbaue
und hinten zu anderen Insel gehe
[Musik]
okay Leute ich unterbreche jetzt mal
ganz kurz die timelaps ihr habt ja schon
gesehen ich habe nicht nur Steine
abgebaut sondern tatsächlich auch Holz
und ich unterbreche die ich einmal
diesen Baum hier zeigen wollte das war
aus einem Setzling ich weiß nicht ob das
mit dem Update kam das jetzt auch solche
fetten oschis irgendwie entstehen können
aus einem einzigen Setzling allerdings
seht ihr schon wir haben genügend
Fichten Setzlinge hier wächst auch die
ganze Zeit was ich kann mich gar nicht
mehr retten vor Holz und das ist auch
ganz gut denn und deswegen ist diese
Folge tatsächlich auch leicht verspätet
die sollte ja eigentlich schon am
Freitag kommen ich habe ja dann
wahrscheinlich meiner Instagram Story
gesehen dass wir spontan mit ein paar
Freunden nach Amsterdam gefahren sind
gesehen Amsterdam am Wochenende soll es
schneien kommen lass ihn Weihnachtsmarkt
dies das schlussendlich hat kein
bisschen geschneit es hat nur geregnet
es war extrem kalt wir haben richtig
gefroren und hatten keine Winterjacke
dabei und natürlich naja schlussendlich
habe ich nicht mehr geschafft ein Video
aufzunehmen hier Skyblock mit Luca ich
hätte wahrscheinlich so eine
sagen können
Problem ist allerdings dass ich ja
eigentlich gesagt habe dass ich in
dieser Folge jetzt mein Haus baue und
alles so ein bisschen ja mal
professionell in die Hand nehme und mich
halt auch auf die Folge sehr intensiv
vorbereitet das habe ich hier jetzt
heute getan ich habe in meiner testwelt
ein Haus vorgebaut was wir heute
hoffentlich bauen werden dafür benötigen
wir eine Menge Fichtenholz eine Menge
sind das hier ein Stein Mama mich nicht
denn gesetzt wir werden ganz ganz viele
Materialien dafür benötigen unfassbar
viele Zäune soundtore es wird eine
Mischung sein aus äh in meinem
starterhaus in Minecraft mit Luca
Staffel 1 und sonst Skyblock tauglich im
Haus da oben ist auch noch ein Setzling
ich werde jetzt auch ähm die normalen
Setzlinge hier kurz tauschen gegen
Fichten weil das ist egal wir haben
wirklich genug mittlerweile guck mal
hier vorne ist auch noch was gewachsen
sind die Monster habe ich noch gar nicht
geschaut ist da irgendwas gedroppt
wahrscheinlich habe ich habe ich
zeitlich nicht geschafft mir das zu
holen nee guck mal ist alles weg naja
egal wir brauchen auf jeden Fall auch
noch auf Dauer ein bisschen Knochen
jetzt schaut euch das mal an
auf welcher Höhe dieser Baum war
naja euch auf jeden Fall noch mal eine
ganz kurze timeless ihr seht schon ich
habe genügend bruchsteinstufe um zum
nächsten Insel zu kommen
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ist irgendwie
eine richtige timeless Folge aber muss
auch heute mal sein weil wir eine Menge
schaffen wollen und auch müssen ihr seht
hier unten schon ich habe mir ganz ganz
viele bruchsteinstufen gemacht von daher
mache ich jetzt wieder eine kleine
Harakiri Aktion und baue mich hier an
der Seite runter bzw es ist leider hier
runter und setze während ich im
Wasserfall bin einfach mal hier drunter
so ein paar bruchsteinstufen so dass ich
gleich eine Ebene ein bisschen weiter
unterhalb der Sandinsel machen kann zack
das Wasser nehmen wir uns wieder und
jetzt kann ich hier unten einen Stein
draufsetzen Zack und befinde mich jetzt
deutlich unter der Sandinsel weil das
bei der Sand Insel glaube ich auch
notwendig ist ihr kennt vielleicht noch
aus äh Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 ach
guck mal so groß ist das Ding egal ähm
ihr kennt vielleicht auch aus Minecraft
Staffel 1 wenn man Sand abbaut der in
der Luft schwebt dann fällt der runter
und rechts den ganzen anderen Sand mit
euch jetzt hier wieder eine kleine
trageplattform das hier vorne sollte
hier mit ausreichen und hier vorne
machen wir vielleicht auch noch mal eine
Seite mehr zack zack zack so dass wenn
ich jetzt das ganze abbaue
alles fällt hin es war auf jeden Fall
sinnvoll von daher brauche ich das ja
auch jetzt direkt wieder ab wir haben
zwar zu anderen Insel zur birkeninsel
auch noch so einen fetten langen Stift
mit Dings das hier vorne müssen wir auch
mal fix Namen Hintergrund mit diesem
Wasserfall der darunter geht habe ich
einfach keine Buchstaben mehr hingesetzt
also das hier vorne wird auf jeden Fall
heute gefixt das hier hinten wird nicht
mehr gefixt der ganze Weg den müssen wir
wann anders abbauen das ähm werde ich
irgendwann mal in der Insel Reparatur
voll gemacht wo wir dann alles äh
timeless mäßig einfach hier abbauen ein
Livestream für sowas wäre perfekt das
haben wir auch einige von euch unten in
die Kommentar geschrieben ihr habt ja
auch schon gemerkt heute ich habe noch
gar keine einzigen Kommentaren
eingeblendet weil ich jetzt erstmal
wirklich mich damit beschäftigen muss
was meine eigene Notizen angeht also
Tipps und Hinweise sind natürlich wie
immer gerne gehen dann bei der nächsten
Folge auch wieder mit Einblendung etc
aber jetzt gerade geht es eher darum
dass ich hier erstmal selber so ein
bisschen klarkommen muss ich
werde das hier mal so ein bisschen
zumindest wieder abbauen oh nein nicht
dass ich mich da selber mit abbaut habe
ich ein bisschen Schiss vor Ort ich
mache es mal so besser dass ich mich
hier drauf Stelle sag sag
und jetzt bauen wir von hier
[Musik]
zumindest keine Plattform mehr und
können diesen ganzen Weg und den Weg der
sich dort hinten befindet irgendwann
anders abbauen euch allerdings
tatsächlich jetzt wieder eine kleine
timelapse
für mich ist also ich bin in der
Aufnahme bei Minute 55 für euch ist
wahrscheinlich nicht mal Minute 6
aber timelapse und ich bereite alle
Sachen vor die wir für den Hausbau
benötigen
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren wenn ich mal
in meinen Inventar schaue seht ihr schon
ich habe ordentlich was vorbereitet paar
Sachen von euch auch tatsächlich nicht
allerdings ähm ja hat ein bisschen was
gedauert ihr dieser dass sie auch nicht
mal gehen ne das nervt mich total also
es ist schön dass gerade so ein bisschen
die Insel belebt ist da vorne sich noch
ein bisschen Fichten
es ist schön dass die Insel ein bisschen
belebter ist aber ich hätte die auch
gerne nicht hier weil irgendwie finde
ich das Projekt doch ganz schön dadurch
dass es dir nicht so querlich ist wie
bei Minecraft mit Lukas Staffel 1 so wie
es sich am Ende entwickelt hat weil
alles voll mit Tieren waren mit mir
geredet und man konnte gefühlte Folge
damit verbringen in der man gar nichts
gemacht hat einfach nur rumlaufen und
gucken was die anderen so machen na gut
ähm ihr seht schon ich packe gerade die
ganze Sachen rein und war auch das hier
gerade ab und werde jetzt auch mal meine
Buchstaben
zu machen jetzt müssen wir noch
aufpassen für die Wasserquelle irgendwie
offen lassen hier ist der Lava einmal
drin dürfen wir nicht schauen was wir
allerdings haben ist noch eine Menge
Erde dies hier 55 Stück die benötigen
wir auf jeden Fall ich werde das jetzt
mal ganz kurz Abbauen der Cobblestone
Generator wird nämlich woanders hin
verfrachtet da hier können wir mal so
ein bisschen drauf rumhüpfen damit wir
hier nicht mehr diesen Nährboden haben
sondern alles ein bisschen austrocknet
zack zack zack zack zack zack hallo
wollte mal hier danke danke
und danke so hier vorne ist auch noch
zwei können wir mal ganz kurz drauf
hüpfen und zack zack so dann haben wir
hier auf jeden Fall die Wasserquelle
weiterhin am Start werden jetzt
allerdings unser Haus bauen und dafür
als allererstes diese Wand hier abreißen
die ist nämlich eben ein bisschen hohl
weil wir ja die Insel eh schon in die
rechte Seite hier so ein bisschen
erweitert haben von daher können wir es
auch direkt hier wegmachen zack zack und
dann hier vorne die Bruchstein auch weg
habe ich jetzt ein bisschen Schiss ich
weiß nicht ob ich überall sauber
gearbeitet habe mit der mit dem
unterhöhlen von den Dingern warte mal so
zack schnell sein
und zack schnell sein und dann haben wir
das ja auf jeden Fall auch am Start
können dann auch hier vorne das
theoretisch auch abreißen aber ich lasse
das glaube ich erstmal hier weil das
hier das ist brauchen wir gar nicht
diese Leuchten oder ich mache die Weg es
ist wirklich also der sieht jetzt ist
jetzt eine leuchtbeere aber auch das
hatten wir auch schon zu Beginn ich
setze jetzt mal provisorisch erstmal
eine Fackel hier dran dass sie nichts
spawnt genauso wie hier vorne da müssen
wir echt ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
aber auf den Herbst können ja glaube ich
meine Ansicht nach eh keine Monster
bauen gut der Baum kommt uns glaube ich
ein bisschen in die Quere von daher muss
ich den auch noch mal ganz kurz eben
Abfällen BAM und hier oben auch meistens
sind ja diese
fichtenholzbäume ein oder Fichten auch
einfach einen Block höher als abbauen
kann hier alles geklappt und jetzt
nehmen wir unsere Erde und äh Kleist
dann das hier mehr oder weniger alles so
ein bisschen zu wir kriegen ja auf Dauer
auch noch ein bisschen mehr Erde durch
die anderen Inseln also ein bisschen was
können wir auf jeden Fall machen den
Rest unserer Insel müssen wir dann
allerdings erweitern durch Holz da
geht's dann leider nicht mehr mit Erde
Winter weil wir halt nur eine gewisse
Anzahl an Erde haben und die ist jetzt
erreicht hier vorne die Erde kann ich
theoretisch auch noch mal mitnehmen aber
ich will noch so ein bisschen mehr
Fichtenholz haben weil ich damit
eigentlich alles machen möchte ich trau
mich auch nicht rechts rüber zu gucken
auf die
monsterinsel ich hatte vorhin bei der
Monster Insel ab und zu mal geschaut ob
da also als Tag war gerade wieder frisch
gleich ist auch neue Tag und dann 23 mal
schauen ob irgendwas fallen lassen haben
die haben allerdings nichts gedroppt
leider und dann müssen wir da uns noch
ein bisschen gedulden bis wir ein
bisschen mehr bauen will haben aber ich
glaube wir haben ja sogar noch ein
bisschen was ne haben wir nicht egal
also nicht mehr lange drum rum quatschen
wir fangen an mit dem Bauen später
oh mein Gott
ey das ist doch nicht weit kommen wir
wieder diese ich habe nicht mal was um
die Sachen als reinzupacken was ich
immer ganz kurz provisorischerweise hier
so ein Fass stell das hier vorne hin und
sicher einfach mal alles was ich gerade
im Inventar habe weil die mich ja
absolut wieder töten werden zack zack
zack so die sind aber halt nicht schnell
genug ne
aber wie oft kommen die denn jetzt
das kannst du dir doch auch nicht
ausdenken verbrennen die eigentlich wenn
es
hey ganz kurze time ist wie ich mit
diesem Idioten hier Kämpfe
[Musik]
so haben wir getötet Sonne geht hier
vorne gleich auch schon wieder direkt
auf zwei Herzen habe ich nur noch extrem
entspannt und wir haben eine phantomhaut
damit kann ich wohl irgendwie was
reparieren wird mir damals meine
Kommentare geschrieben ich weiß nicht
was ich glaube eine elytra oder so dann
der Mann dann rumfliegen kann aber da
bin ich so weit von entfernt von daher
brauche ich von Thomas eigentlich
erstmal nicht wir konzentrieren uns
allerdings auf das Haus ähm
beziehungsweise acht Glas haben wir wir
haben hier vorne können wir erstmal
wieder eine Challenge machen und zwar
wenn wir 16 Glasscheiben craften haben
wir die nächste Challenge am Start
[Musik]
haben wir hier oben tatsächlich auch den
Fortschritt Paint collector gerade
erzählt dass es auch in Minecraft
irgendwie anscheinend eine Challenge
guck mal ist da vorne was gespannt nee
müssen wir mal kurz hinlaufen vielleicht
ist es dann jetzt mit seiners generiert
aber nee ist wieder nichts ich weiß
nicht warum das liegt aber nicht hier
irgendwie wird fallen lassen von unserem
Monstern schreibt mir da auch gerne
unten in die Kommentare wie ich an mehr
bauen mir ran komme ich muss auf diesem
Weg hier noch mal sichern sonst alles
schöner gemacht werden und wir fangen
jetzt an und zwar starten wir vier
Blöcke Abstand von hier mit Treppen mit
natürlicher aus welchem Material welche
man sonst Fichtenholz dann hier zack Bam
Bam noch mal einmal drauf Bam Bam Bam
Bam noch mal welche drauf und dann
machen wir hier Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
das ist der Eingang den hatten wir auch
so auf der
Seite von unserem Haus bei Minecraft mit
Luca Staffel 1 eigentlich würde ich
gerne hier an den Rand äh so diese
Dinger hier packen am liebsten von
Eichenbäumen die Blätter weil die so
schön grün sind das klappt allerdings
nicht weil wir leider keine
ähm Schere haben und die Teile abzubauen
von daher machen wir weiter mit unserem
kleinen farmbereich hier drunter wir
gehen drei hoch drei zur Seite und dann
hier wieder drei runter also Seite dann
hier wieder zack zack zack drei runter
es fehlt uns hier ein bisschen Erde ähm
ich werde mal einfach hier vorne den
Baum abbauen Zack und ich werde auch mal
hier vorne die Erde abbauen so dass wir
einfach zumindest zwei Erde mehr haben
die wir hier vorne hinsetzen können die
Sache ist allerdings das fällt mir auch
gerade auf ich mache mir auch erstmal
ganz kurz glaube ich eine
Schaufel ich habe sogar die passende
Sache noch mit dem Inventar weil ich
tatsächlich ähm mir gerade gedacht habe
wir können ja ganz entspannt bisschen
tricksen und können sagen ich bin
eigentlich kein Fan von Tricks und ihr
wisst das von Minecraft Staffel 1 ich
möchte dass selbst wenn hier der Boden
aus Stein wäre und man würde diesen
Bereich da nicht sehen würde ich
trotzdem wollen das jetzt komme ich da
unten hin ne ich bin so ein Idiot ähm
ich mal vorher daran gedacht aber das
ist immer nur spontan eingefallen selbst
wenn eigentlich man hier drunter das
nicht sehen würde was ihr für
Materialien sind möchte ich trotzdem
eigentlich nur für mein Gewissen dass
dort die Materialien sind die überall
verbaut wurden machen wir hier jetzt
nicht wir setzen darunter jetzt einfach
Steine ich weiß nicht ob ich hier vorne
die reingepackt habe ja fünf Stück
verdammt das reicht jetzt natürlich
nicht äh zack zack zack ich hätte noch
was können wir denn noch nehmen wir
nehmen mal noch Fichtenholz Bretter nee
ich habe ich habe ganz ganz viele
Eichenstämme kommen ein bisschen
Eichenholz äh dürfen wir müssen da
irgendwann vergessen dass das hier
drunter gebaut wurde von daher ja euch
da ganz schnell wieder was drüber und
dann könnte man denken dass sie
tatsächlich die ganze Zeit nur Erde
runter ist aber dann haben wir ein
bisschen mehr Erde um damit halt einfach
zu arbeiten hier vorne setzen wir
Steinziegel drunter allerdings auch nur
dort denn hier können wir uns auch die
Steinziegel sparen setzen Eichen und
dann hier vorne wieder eine Erde weil er
hier tatsächlich was drauf kommt gleich
also bleibt auf jeden Fall dran hier
vorne auch noch mal nee nicht
Fichtenholz sondern wir setzen hier
vorne auch Eichenholz drunter bei
Fichtenholz haben wir nicht so viel wird
sich auf Dauer ein bisschen switchen
weil ihr seht schon wie viele
tatsächlich am wachsen schon wieder drei
neue Bäume die sehen auch viel schöner
aus finde ich als die Eichenbäume bzw so
ein mischmaschke mehr vielleicht machen
na ja gut ich ablenken Luca hier vorne
kommen auf jeden Fall fester und Truhen
hin besser zack zack und Truhe
das machen wir am Ende würde ich sagen
äh dieser Bereich hier der muss mit Erde
auf jeden Fall voll bleiben denn äh ihr
wisst ja hier vorne wieder drei rüber
zack also vier rüber und dann drei hoch
drei rüber BAM hier kommt eine kleine
Farmen alle die Minecraft Lukas Staffel
1 geguckt haben was ich tatsächlich nur
empfehlen kann ich doch gerade in der
Weihnachtszeit das ist ein sehr sehr
schönes Projekt so dumm wie ich das die
ganze Zeit selber Bewerber ich bin echt
stolz auf dieses Projekt und ich finde
es schön geschafft haben da hatten wir
das ja auch so gebaut dass wir unter
unserem Haus und eine kleine Farm hatten
schlussendlich haben wir mehr und mehr
andere Farben Möglichkeiten genutzt und
anderes Essen gegessen allerdings
Regen beim Hausbau das stört gar nicht
ich muss mal eben fix meinen lavaeimer
hier vorne hinsetzen BAM so dass ich den
einmal benutzen kann um hier in die
Mitte Wasser zu machen
[Musik]
jetzt geht's
na gut okay keine Ahnung was das war
entsprechend immer die Lava aber mal
wieder mit Packen hier rein bevor wir
noch irgendwas aus Versehen zu bauen und
dann ist die Lava weg weil die brauchen
wir auf jeden Fall Stone jetzt nehmen
wir uns eine Falltür wo haben wir denn
hier 22 Falltüren haben wir und können
die ganz entspannt hier draufsetzen das
Wasser ist trotzdem noch am Start seht
ihr allerdings haben wir jetzt die
Möglichkeit mittels einer Fackel hier
unten für ein bisschen Belichtung zu
sorgen und in unserer steinhacke hier
vorne drumherum kleines Feld zu machen
wo wir unser Weizen anpflanzen können
nehmen wir das hier vorne auch noch mal
eben mit da haben wir auch noch ein paar
Körner und ist da was soll der Geist wie
craften uns die Kisten einfach mal eben
kurz neu zack da brauche ich noch ähm
einmal brauche ich noch zack zack zack
weil bevor das dann nachher so ein
Stress wird wieder abbauen und dann
alles ganz schnell darüber
hinsetzen hier wusste nicht genau was
ich hier machen sollte weil da kann man
halt durch gucken man könnte es halt so
regeln man sieht allerdings wenn man
jemand durchpassen würde auf der anderen
Seite so aus und das Problem ist auch oh
mein Gott mein Wecker klingelt das
Problem ist auch mein Gott ist schon hey
ich nehme schon viel zu lange auf das
Problem ist auch dass wenn ich hier die
Kiste jetzt öffne seht ihr in der
Animation das geht da so rein ich werde
jetzt erstmal so lassen wenn ihr eine
bessere Idee habt
ich weiß es nicht ich finde es nicht so
schön dass man das hier ich nehme das
halt die ganze Zeit war dann würde ich
lieber ich glaube ich äh schreib mir mal
in die Kommentare ob ihr das machen
würdet oder nicht andersrum wird's halt
so aussehen ich glaube ich lasse es
erstmal frei und dann schauen wir mal
wie ich das schlussendlich mache na ja
gut auf jeden Fall können wir dann hier
unten so ein bisschen Weizen anbauen und
können hier vorne dann die ganzen weiten
Sachen reinpacken und generell so eine
kleine naturkiste machen hier dann
irgendwie was mit steigen und jeder
ganze Rest das ist auf jeden Fall der
untere Bereich der ist jetzt schon
fertig und im oberen Bereich nehmen wir
jetzt unsere Fichtenholz Bretter bzw
können auch theoretisch ich weiß nicht
ob ich Fichtenholz Stufen oder
Fichtenholz Bretter nehmen muss oder
soll da bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz
sicher weil mit den Stufen wird so
aussehen ich glaube das ist besser mit
Stufen dann haben wir unten ein bisschen
mehr Platz und deswegen nicht so
gedrängt ja sie besser aus mit Stufen
machen wir das mit Stufen
dann brauche ich allerdings noch ein
paar mehr dass man eben kurz so machen
zack das sollte reichen und das ist
unser Boden so ein bisschen jetzt nehmen
wir unser entrindetes Eichenholz packen
das hier hin und hier sechs Stück
brauchen wir davon denn darauf setzen
wir jetzt unsere Glasscheiben Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam und auch auf dieser Seite
Bam Bam Bam Bam das dazwischen wird
jetzt äh getragen von auch in drinnen
Eichen allerdings den Stämmen damit die
oben halt ein bisschen schöner aussehen
und hier die letzten drei zack zack zack
die Bäume hier das ist eigentlich ganz
schön dass sie so direkt da dran sind
Stopp die lass ich sogar stehen dann
könnte ich hier vorne auch noch mal
einen einpflanzen habe ich noch einen
Setzling nicht ich glaube nicht ist
irgendeiner gedroppt worden auch nicht
äh können wir mal gucken dass wir den
hier vielleicht dann hier vorne setzen
ist das alles ein bisschen Cosi er wird
da müssen aber auch noch ein paar Eichen
Pflanzen aber es wird alles das Gras
wird ja auch noch rumwachsen sieht das
hier ein bisschen weniger wie kacke aus
ich habe ja noch ein bisschen Erde mir
die Pizza kann ich mir tatsächlich auch
von hier drunter auf dann machen wir das
hier nämlich so Zack und auch auf dieser
Seite zack dann haben wir noch mal zwei
Erde mehr so mal können wir das ganz
entspannt so machen da denkt man da
drunter ist hier die ganze Zeit
irgendwas anderes selber wenn man da mal
genau hinschaut Eiche und wir haben die
ganze Zeit deswegen habe ich auch hier
vorne die steinziegeln hingesetzt weil
man das halt bei diesem wenn diese nur
diese ein bisschen niedriger wenn man da
was anpflanzt deswegen sieht man den
Bereich halt aber gut okay hier soll
halt wie gesagt eigentlich äh Blätter
hin geht halt leider nicht oder kümmern
uns um den Bereich oben da habe ich mir
nämlich gedacht hier vorne das ganze mit
Fichtenholz Zäunen zu machen weil ich
das mit Glas nicht so ganz sehen würde
man könnte auch Glasscheiben hinmachen
aber ich finde es cool wenn so ein
bisschen offen ist von daher können wir
uns auch jetzt schon direkt ums Dach
kümmern brauchen dafür allerdings noch
ein Lagerfeuer da muss ich noch mal ganz
kurz nehmen bei Google wie Lagerfeuer
Minecraft immer gecraftet wird das
irgendwas mit unten
und dann noch Holz und Kohle haben wir
aber auch alles am Start weil das
Problem ist ich hatte ja Lagerfeuer
allerdings
war das Problem jetzt habe ich keine
Stöcker allerdings war das Problem dass
wenn man so ein Lagerfeuer abbaut dass
man dann nur ein Kohle gedroppt bekommt
und
ja wegen ganz Lagerfeuer brauchen aber
gut okay das sieht jetzt noch ein
bisschen doof hier aus wird gleich
schöner aussehen Fichtenholz Stufen komm
jetzt hier drauf setzen wir bis hierhin
und setzen wir auch hier vorne rum jetzt
nehmen wir allerdings nee warte mal
Moment wir müssen noch ich habe hier
rechts an der Seite gerade mein Ding
offen mein ähm meine testwelt wo ich
Fotos gemacht habe wie ich das
letztendlich bauen möchte jetzt nehmen
wir unsere Fichtenholz Falltüren und
setzen die hier so an den Rand so ein
bisschen als Überdach Zack und das
machen wir auf jeder Seite auch hier ich
habe erst überlegt ist hier nicht zu
machen weil das sehen wir eh nicht und
ich bin mir ein Fan davon weißt du denn
so eine Wand hast den Fernseher dann
auch beispielsweise jetzt noch gezogen
den Fernseher nicht mittig zu setzen
sondern eher links passiert damit ich
kriegt man klar würde man simple
Mathematik auch easy hinkriegen aber nur
so vom Ding her lieber wenn das Sofa
dann auch links ist dann den Fernseher
auch links wisst ihr wie ich meine und
nicht mittig alles aber gut wir machen
jetzt hier auf jeden Fall so dass wir
diesen Bereich hier vorne das
lass nicht drüber sprechen oder
oh nein
ich hoffe es ist nicht wichtiges
runtergefallen
[Applaus]
oh mein Gott
aber gut ich bin hier hingefallen na gut
wenn hier Items lang kann schon egal wir
lassen uns davon nicht beirren okay wenn
hier sogar Items sagen dann ist safe
irgendwas wichtiges runtergefallen aber
das Glas haben wir auf jeden Fall das
ist auf jeden Fall endlich aber sonst
alles andere ich hatte ja nicht so viele
wichtige Sachen es war no job nicht
extra dass ich da gerade runtergefallen
bin also nicht dass mir irgendwie was
unterstellt weil man darf sich ja nicht
absichtlich töten in Skyblock wichtig
ist nur dass wir die Erde noch haben
aber gut okay wir bauen jetzt auf jeden
Fall weiter ich habe nämlich das hier so
ein bisschen anders gebaut eigentlich
als ich jetzt hier gerade an Leute das
war nämlich so wie folgt das waren hier
ganz normale
ganz normale Fichtenholz Bretter Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam nee das war ein zu hoch sag
dem wieder abbauen mit der Axt besser
dann geht schneller und den hier auch
noch mal abbauen weil ähm wie ich gerade
bereits gesagt habe ich immer noch meine
Fackel hier nee andere Hand damit ihr
ein bisschen sieht ähm es ist ein
bisschen schöner wenn es nicht ganz
perfekt ist meine Ansicht nach so nehmen
wir brauchen noch ein bisschen was so
und auf dieser Seite hier auch zack du
kommst weg und du kommst auch weg und
dann können wir nämlich jetzt auf dieser
Seite hier habe ich mir gedacht mit
bruchsteinstufen mit Steinziegel Stufen
und mit einem Lagerfeuer das ganze so
machen hier hier und hier ein Lagerfeuer
in die Mitte dann sieht es nämlich das
ist das Wasser glaube ich auch sogar
schon äh dann sieht sie mich von außen
so aus also nicht so ganz genau ach guck
mal hier perfekt weiß ich nicht so ganz
genau wie das von außen aussieht aber es
sieht zumindest aus als wäre es ein
Schornstein müssen wir hier vorne
natürlich noch die Erde abbauen und
unsere Items rüberkriegen denn äh
storage soll unten sein und oben sollen
äh diese Sachen hier sein die wir
benötigen um Sachen dann wirklich zu
craften also unsere Werkbank und unser
erster Ofen und unser zweiter Ofen waren
beide nichts mehr drin und dann nehmen
wir diese Sachen hier direkt mal kurz
mit hoch und können jetzt hier vorne
eine
Werkbank hinsetzen und dann machen wir
Ofen und Ofen oder lieber nebeneinander
ich glaube besser lieber nebeneinander
aber das Problem ist dann immer dass
sich dieser Ofen dann damit verbindet
hier wenn ich ganz so schön aus aber gut
wir lassen das jetzt einfach mal so dann
können wir hier auf jeden Fall alles so
ein bisschen schön craften und unsere
Items packen wir jetzt mal rüber hier
vorne in die Kisten ich würde jetzt
einfach mal hier vorne anfangen mit Holz
Sachen oben BAM das hier würde ich mal
so ein bisschen anders und dass er
wirklich auf die Steine Sachen beziehen
ähm
oder soll ich doch anders auf denn ich
weiß es nicht dann mache ich die ganzen
unnötigen Sachen das heißt unnötige
Sachen aber die ganzen Sachen die so ein
bisschen wertvoller sind mache ich mal
hier unten rein du bekommst hier hin du
kommst da oh ich habe auf jeden Fall
mein Schwert von uns fällt mir gerade
auf ähm und jetzt äh bei euch die Kiste
auch nicht ab weil ich nicht will dass
irgendwas da irgendwie rüber fliegt ich
nehme jetzt jedes einzelne item einzeln
raus und dann schauen wir einfach wo was
reinpacken also erstmal die naturkiste
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack
nee kommt
hier das Holz jetzt erstmal nach oben
Holz Spitzhacke natürlich auch Hölzern
und das diese ganzen Sachen die so ein
bisschen wertvoller sind packen wir hier
unten rein Schlamm wertvoll genau
Schnee weiß auch noch nicht genau wofür
man gerufen Druckplatten alles klar
Stein Druckplatten das waren challenges
die wir hatten ne ähm Stein Sachen
kommen natürlich in andere Kiste und
hier vorne Leinen ein bisschen Erde
nehmen wir für gleich Lava einmal müssen
wir dann nächste Folge dann auch ein
bisschen schöneren
Generator bauen fällt mir gerade auf
weil wir aktuell gerade gar keinen haben
und dann nehmen wir diese Sachen mit und
können dann auch jetzt die Kiste hier
mitnehmen guck mal die Erde geht schon
ganz langsam rüber aber die kommt ja
auch von der anderen Seite so ein
bisschen müssen wir hier noch Erde
hinsetzen damit das hier rumgeht so ein
bisschen schneller vielleicht zack zack
zack zack so mehr da haben wir nicht und
die restlichen Sachen packen wir dann
auch mal ganz kurz hier rein erstmal das
hier in die Kiste von Natur verrottetes
Fleisch packen wir mal hier unten mit
rein und Holz mit nach oben ich crafte
mir noch mal eben schnell ein neues
Schwert jetzt habe ich keine
Bruchsteine mehr dafür oder was ja okay
ich brauche auf jeden Fall ein
Cobblestone Generator allerdings bin ich
tatsächlich fast bei anderthalb Stunden
mittlerweile
dementsprechend meine Damen und Herren
Haus
abgeschlossen zwei Challenge ist heute
geschafft Glasscheiben und Haus wenn es
euch gefallen hat lasst gerne einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
ich habe was vergessen
so wir haben es meine Damen und Herren
die Beleuchtung ist wichtig damit da
nichts spawnt etc pp ich weiß auch nicht
ob ich hier vorne alles vernünftig
ausgeleuchtet habe ja sollte passen hier
unten ist ja egal das von eh nichts
allerdings wie bereits gesagt an der
Stelle würde ich das Video auch beenden
wir äh ich werde gar nicht sagen wenn
wir uns wiedersehen irgendwann die
nächsten Tage kommt eine neue Folge und
äh dann hat sie hoffentlich aufgehört zu
regnen und vielleicht sind ein paar
Monster Sachen gespannt und was war dann
genau machen
kann ich euch noch nicht sagen
schreibt's in die Kommentare ihr dürft
entscheiden ich schau mal dann in die
Kommentare bis dann dann machen wir das
krank wie viel wir geschafft haben und
krank wie lange die Folge auch trotzdem
geworden ist obwohl wir jetzt so viele
timelapse hatten habe ich lieb haut rein
danke
[Musik]